- [Narrator] Your breakfast
may be getting more expensive.
Across the board, Americans
are paying more for food.
Since last year, the cost of
bacon has gone up by over 10%,
6.2% for fresh fruit and 0.2% for cereal.
It may not seem like a
lot, but all of these
little increases add up,
and it's not just food,
it's goods and services
across the economy.
After years of low inflation,
that hovered around 2%
the consumer price index, the
benchmark measure of inflation
in the US, jumped 4.2% in
April from the year before.
These increases are often
felt at the grocery store,
which is why it's affecting
the price of your breakfast.
This has created a lot of concern
over whether higher prices
are a temporary blip, or here to stay.
- During this time of reopening,
we are likely to see some
upward pressure on prices.
- [Narrator] So here's why
you're paying more for your breakfast
and whether the current price jumps
are a bellwether of inflation to come.
A major factor for increased
food prices as corn,
which has soared roughly 50% in 2021.
Even if you don't have
cornflakes for breakfast,
many foods have ingredients
derived from the grain
or come from animals who eat it.
Corn makes up over 96% of all
animal feed grain production
in the US, and around 1/5 of the US crop
is exported to other countries.
Like China, right now the country
is on a corn buying binge.
Farmers are racing to
fatten millions of hogs
to replace the pigs it had to kill
during the 2020 outbreak
of African swine fever.
It's expected to import about
four times more corn in 2021,
mostly from US farmers.
On top of that, drought
in corn producing regions
in south America have led
to disappointing crop yields
and logistical problems.
In Argentina, multiple years of drought
have made the Parana River
too shallow for boats
fully loaded with grain to pass
from the country's interior
to Atlantic shipping lanes.
Simply put, the higher
demand for feed corn
from China and smaller
supply from South America
means more expensive sausage and bacon.
But that's not all that corn is doing
to raise the price for your breakfast.
It's also making it more expensive
to ship food across the country.
About 10% of the gasoline
consumed in the United States
is ethanol, which is made from corn.
So the rise in price for
the grain has contributed
to higher gas prices, but
also finding truck drivers
to move the food has been difficult.
Shipping demand for
truck freight has risen
as the economy has emerged from lockdowns.
To lure new recruits, trucking
companies have raised pay,
further driving up the price of shipping.
Kellogg's, maker of cereal brands
like Frosted Flakes, has said
that higher shipping costs
have contributed to it raising prices,
and those shipping problems
haven't stopped at the water's edge.
Ocean Freight has made it
more expensive to ship sugar,
whose price has risen over 3%.
The global supply chain
slowdown last year,
as well as the closing of
the Suez Canal in March,
have backed up shipping for months.
But economists say food prices
are not the best indicator
for tracking inflation
across the entire economy.
There are a few reasons for that.
According to senior Wall Street Journal
economics writer, Jon Hilsenrath.
- It's a very goods oriented
sector of the economy
as opposed to a labor oriented
sector of the economy,
like a service sector where labor costs
really drive the cost of the product.
- [Narrator] A more telling indicator
for broader inflation
might be what you're paying
for that same breakfast at a restaurant.
While overall food prices have
jumped 2.4% from a year ago,
restaurant meals have gone up 3.8%.
One reason is restaurants
just have more expenses.
For example, takeout
trays became more costly
after a February winter storm
knocked out plastics production in Texas.
And another reason is the
increased cost of labor.
Rising vaccination rates, easing lockdowns
and federal stimulus aid have
boosted consumer spending.
Yet employers, including
restaurant owners,
are struggling to find workers.
As the economy has
rebounded, so have wages,
but participation in the
labor force has flattened.
- Some people moved out of dense cities
that were seen as being unsafe
because of the pandemic.
And so as restaurants reopen,
it might be a geographic problem,
that there just might not
be people in the place.
And then we also have to think
about the policy effects.
So the government has
thrown a lot of money
at supporting workers who
were affected by the pandemic.
And some workers at this
point might just be saying,
while they're still getting
these unemployment benefits
might be saying, you know what?
I don't have to rush back to work.
- [Narrator] Fast food
restaurants have started
to offer perks like signing bonuses
and free college tuition in a
bid to lower hourly workers.
All this adds up to
pricier meals for diners.
- I think most people would agree
that we wanna see wages rising.
Particularly for lower
skill, low-income workers,
when wages are rising, that
means they're better off.
That means they're bringing
home bigger paychecks.
What we don't want to see is
wage increases paired together
with inflation increases that
start feeding on each other
and leave workers actually
worse off and not better off.
- [Narrator] This effect,
known as a wage price spiral,
contributed to the high
inflation of the 1970s,
but will history repeat itself?
The federal reserve for its part has said
prices will correct as supply
and demand forces even out.
- These one-time increases in prices
are likely to have only
transitory effects on inflation.
- [Narrator] For now,
indicators that measure
expectations of inflation,
like treasury bond yields,
remain low, suggesting
people expect inflation
to be modest, at least in the near term.
So for now, consumers will have to adjust
to some rising prices for their
breakfast, whether at home
or at the diner, just don't
forget to include the tip.
(gentle music)